[Music]
we're celebrating hometowns all season
long isn't this country amazing so many
special places that we get to call home
because there is no place like home
and for second grade teacher tatiana
ainese that's washington dc our nation's
capital and she's about to show us
around
take it away tatiana
hey drew my name is kasianemi i'm an
elementary school teacher right here in
washington dc now dc has been my home
for the past couple of years and i love
it here one of the things that i love
about dc is this rich history and
culture now about to go check out union
market it's my favorite place to hit up
right after work so let's go
my first stop when i come to uni market
is i always go to pudding pudding is a
new orleans southern comfort food all
wrapped in one honestly the bread
pudding is delicious but everything on
the menu is delicious i normally order
the shrimp and grits or the souffet so
if you're at u market check out pudding
we're here at meridian hale park what's
the locals actually crawling my friends
little know fact i didn't even know it
was called meridian hill park i've
always referred says malcolm x park now
on sundays they have a drum circle and
it's absolutely youth like live music on
a sunday why not it's my favorite place
to come when i just want to chill out
want to walk my dog go for a run it's
just the peace in the middle of a city
all right drew that's just a little
snapshot it's the washington dc i hope
you love it as much as i do listen next
time you're in town hit me up girls i'll
see you soon
well thank you tatyana that was amazing
i love dc so much you cannot go there
and not be awestruck by the history by
the way have you ever had a summer in dc
whew that is humidity i will tell you um
the cherry blossoms the museums it's
just
thank you for taking us through your dc
and we'll be right back
[Music]
you